welcome to this video playing FM juga da
as you godda or something I really
absolutely have no idea about the
Spanish language so please forgive me
for screwing this pronunciation up like
that so early p 3 yeah playing without
b5 here for change going for a quick if
you cheat oh it's not a bad setup okay
okay let me just repeat it can I go d5
now may be opening up okay prepare that
I guess okay now do not the five that
shouldn't be bad if he takes I'm happy
95 and it's not going to avoid this
Bishop 23 being traded
hmm
okay I didn't really see that one coming
but why not
okay let's see maybe I can do something
with night f4 here it's not really
believing that I can do something in mmm
I'm not so sure jack takes Bishop takes
Queen has to move Queen g4 made so this
is a nice porn that I had that snatched
them and I have fish up h3 here and
possibly Bishop g2 push up g 291 okay I
think I can do this I can do this anyway
where is he going where is he going with
the Queen this is the funny thing if he
goes to sea for I can go back at least
okay it doesn't help so what if i go to
age 32 g 291 mm I don't really have a
good square then hmm again it doesn't
have many squares
Bishop Gene 291 cannot really make that
work and Kevin so I'm going back and
just take take the money and run let's
say couldn't find a direct win but this
is just nice as it is
trying to find those complete wins has
cost me many games them then coming into
and the huge time pressure so we want to
cheeky several and then play rugae eight
the I was probably not very precisely
plating I very likely had better better
options but it's still not a bad
position actually wonder if you can take
you five maybe you can do that this is
however looks decent attacking the
knight down and b5 and c3 and quite
quite a lot is hanging what is it going
to play Bishop deform a B and C 5 is an
interesting move see five kings and that
let's do this takes knight takes Bishop
g7 queen takes on the two worst idea I
can at always take on the to the f it
takes
maybe yes scoop should burn III m yeah
okay so can I take a seven
and wow
Wow
I don't see if I have to play something
maybe this is to pacify don't know man
from death good position a screwed-up
don't believe it check now after you try
to win this game all over again then
probably not even better him
and again I can get some a little bit of
a neck a little bit of activity here
Queenie 5 rook takes Queen age 5 check
this kind of thing time warning yeah
let's try that try to be active okay
that was a mistake I guess check mmm
that's there nothing here Bishop g4 for
Bishop f3 maybe check check that's me I
can take every I don't believe this I
don't know check it was again very good
yet then then I overlooked this tactic
ah come on losing this game is a shame a
big shame check check what did it yacht
a game early check check check aah sorry
aah black resigns I mean no I don't
believe it I hope lame like three times
in this game yeah and I still managed to
lose this is crazy yeah I mean here of
course black just wins with a good move
well what what moved his win look be one
win sir probably everything even 25
probably wins that was my original
intention where he has to play a form
yeah and this g5 again wins and I just
overlooked that you can take on f7 are
don't believe this nonsense and capture
just like that it's a pawn yeah I spent
maybe too much time trying to figure out
a win and direct when I mean this this
is probably something but so came what
does what what is the way now in just
just to see it once okay Bishop what is
group d aids winning
don't get it yet maybe because Bishop g2
now is a bigger threat as d to hang so
on let's say place something like this
what is the wind and a queen geforce
dentist idea and then the Queen over
here like just oops no that was not
intended okay now the worst is over fine
Chad yeah okay hip white is OK again but
it it got down here again really quickly
chan and here would be one wins with
Queen D one coming i simply i calculated
Bishop before that line and i didn't see
that at the end he can take on f3 it's
just immensely stupid and this is again
winning maybe i could have throw 35
seconds i should have thought about it
from the moment but this is still wins
we just prepares the whole thing and he
has no way to defend it not nothing
check check that's a brutal thing about
her chest sometimes yet the whole game
is kind of yeah you're close to winning
in many ways and then you make this
miscalculation and add lose this game
okay thanks for watching